Kayla Martin with a good start here Ally
well Kevin we found out some interesting
facts about Caleb Martin and how he got
to this point we were talking to Eric
Bolson before the game and he said A
week before Camp started J Cole yes J
Cole the rapper called assistant coach
karon Butler and said my guy Kayla
Martin is available so coach Butler
passed on the information to Eric
spolster he said could he come we're
scrimmaging tomorrow he showed up in
front of everyone be kind became a
two-way player and ever since was a huge
part of a starting rotation until they
had him decide to sign him full time
there was a match made in heaven from
day one